you are probably aware that we're
getting a Star Wars movie every year for
the foreseeable future before long we'll
be watching the young han Solo movie and
he'll be accompanied by everyone's
favorite Wookiee Disney's Bob Iger
recently confirmed Chewbacca's
appearance while talking about both of
the upcoming Star Wars spin-offs he said
row 1 is about a band of rebels plotting
to steal the plans to the Death Star it
takes place right before what was George
Lucas's first film which came out in
1977 and is now called a new hope we
have others in the works including one
which is an origin story about Han Solo
and chewy and that will come after Star
Wars eight and twenty eighteen and then
there will possibly be more thereafter
the young Han Solo movie will be
directed by phil lord and christopher
miller two names you probably recognize
from the lego movie and 21 Jump Street
and in all likelihood we'll hear about
even more Star Wars spin-offs after that
keep an eye on gamespot for more
information and may the force be with
you